you know someone once said that acting
is the enchanted wand that turns words
into magic thankfully we've had that
person dragged out to the parking lot
and beaten I'm talking about words like
I could have been a contender here's
looking at you kid life is like a box of
chocolates all shining examples of how a
few simple words become cinematic legend
last year as the global film community
knows I made my big-screen debut in a
little something called cabin boy and I
too was lucky enough to turn words into
magic watch closely
would you like to buy a monkey
why don't we enjoy that again would you
like to buy a monkey but you know as
with all great work I was not the first
or only choice here now take a look at
some of my fellow actors who auditioned
for this plum role would you like to buy
a monkey would you like to buy a monkey
I can do one bigger want to buy a donkey
monkey I'm confused I thought I was
playing the monkey what's the matter you
don't like monkeys I like monkey you
like monkey listen here I'm not gonna
ask you again omission one more time you
want to buy the monkey or not huh and I
can do it in German or anything I want
you
Tobias monkey you clear my eyeline
please back there could everybody get
out of my eye line thank you would you
like to buy a monkey Mexican monkey
happy well hey mister wanna buy a monkey
would you like to buy a monkey would you
like to buy a monkey monkey waiting for
phone call monkey monkey after a big
meal you bite us okay
smack upside the head
how about that
so you see how truly blessed I was
ladies and gentlemen here in my right
hand I have a copy of tonight's top ten
list let's get right to it
from the home office in Hollywood
California tonight's top ten list
category top ten signs the movie you're
watching will not win an Academy Award
top ten signs the movie you're watching
will not win an Academy Award here we go
number ten it still has the timecode
from the camcorder on it
number nine any combination of the words
police and Academy in the title number
eight it's a movie about the Civil War
and General Grant is wearing Dockers
number seven you hear someone yelling
focus and you realize it's the director
number six it's a beautifully made
documentary about two kids in the inner
city trying to realize their dream of
playing professional basketball
number five the last 20 minutes is a
shot of Richie from local 262 eating
donuts lesson number four your date had
to jam a hypodermic needle full of
adrenaline into your heart just to keep
you awake number three before it starts
you here thank you for coming to Lowe's
sit back and relax this movie blows
number two a nude scene with Huma
Thurman replaced by nude scene with
Strom Thurmond and the number one sign
the movie you're watching will not win
an Academy Award for words
Dom DeLuise as Gandhi
that is gentlemen it's my pleasure to
introduce the man responsible for all
the wonderful live music on tonight's
program once again occupying a place of
honor beneath the stage returning for
his 11th year as musical director the
maestro and Academy Award winner bill
Conti
you